il est l'un des grands noms du polar à
la française celui dont des dizaines de
milliers de lecteurs attendent chaque
nouveau livre le dernier en date
s'intitule au soleil redouté michel
bussi a accepté notre invitation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis particulièrement heureux de vous
recevoir pour la raison que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est que il ya un
divorce que je ne m'explique pas bien
entre la littérature populaire au sens
le plus noble de l'adjectif et les
émissions culturelles les gens de votre
stature de votre standing vous vendez un
million de livres par an en général ne
veulent pas se confronter une certaine
forme de critique et vous je sais que
vous avez même annulé des invitations
pour être présent parmi nous ce soir je
vous en remercie à nouveau
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez souhaité
nous confronter à la critique est pas
vous contenter du million de lecteurs
qui vous suit chaque année non mais
vraiment on aurait vie universitaire
j'ai été prof de géo l'université donc
la controverse qu'a trois scientifiques
ou culturelles
c'est quelque chose qui m'intéresse
alors votre dernier livre s'intitule au
soleil redouté très beau titre le soleil
redouté c'est aussi le nom d'une pension
de famille homard cuit aux marquises qui
ont été peints par gauguin qui ont été
chantées par jacques brel il est
d'ailleurs question dans le livre est il
ya cinq 5 ans gagné un concours et qui
suivent donc un atelier d'écriture qui
est animé par un auteur pas vraiment
dans votre genre mais un auteur très
populaire aussi alors qu'est ce qui vous
a intéressé dans les marquises pourquoi
ce lieu
d'abord ce qui m'intéressait c'est de
créer un huis clos avec un nombre
d'acteurs limité donc ce sont les
pensionnaires de dos lru d'août et les
lectrices et puis les gens qui se
trouvent aux marquises à ce moment là et
donc c'est le côté agatha christie des
petits [ __ ] c'est à dire non là il ya
un nombre de coupables imiter un crime
peut être d'autres et évidemment le
lecteur va réduire le champ des
possibles au fur et à mesure donc on est
dans un mood honig classique donc
j'avais besoin d'une île alors j'allais
le choix entre une île imaginaire une
île comme la feria christie avec sont
ils des [ __ ] et il a j'ai choisi les
marquises qui s'est vraiment imposée
parce que je voulais une île très très
lointaine vous parlez luigi tual est
alors fortement et donc une île très peu
l'antenne on dit que les marquis chez
l'archipel le plus isolé du monde qu'on
est quand même déjà à quatre heures
d'avion de tahiti et à 6000 km du
premier continent dont il y avait cette
idée qui évidemment une fois qu'on est
là bas avec un crime se produit il faut
se débrouiller tout seul quoi
on se pose la question quand on écrit
une histoire comme les dix petits [ __ ]
est ce que quand on écrit on commence
par la fin est soi même on dit tiens
voilà quel sera le coupable on remonte
ou alors on fait dans on va dans l'ordre
a obligatoirement par évidemment je suis
persuadé qu évidemment garda christie
pour deep tech savait exactement et
l'emmener son lecteur et vous et je n'ai
inventé ce roman que quand j'avais
effectivement l'ensemble de la traîne
d'ailleurs ça se passe sur les marquises
serait puisse passer ailleurs c'est un
roman qui fonctionne sur une
manipulation et cette manipulation
évidemment elle est la base même du
roman et tout le reste y compris les
personnages ne sont là quelque part que
pour alimenter cette machination
non parce que le celui qui anime
l'atelier d'écriture commence par
disparaître
il ya un premier meurtre et ensuite
ensuite j'ai tourné les pages jusqu'à la
fin sous la tombe et voilà moi et fait
plonger dans dans votre livre
mais je reviens un peu en arrière parce
que votre destin l'écrivain a connu des
péripéties presque aussi impressionnante
que vos intrigues
tiens vous à commencer par un premier
roman refusé vous avez attendu très
longtemps avant d'en publier en plus
c'était des presses universitaires dont
c'est un peu étrange
et le succès est venu bien après et je
dois savoir si dans votre approche de
l'écriture ou de votre carrière
d'écrivain il reste quelque chose de ses
débuts atypique une forme d'humilité ou
de doute je pense que le fait de
commencer à avoir du succès ou même
publié un premier roman
après 40 ans voire 50 ans fait que notre
vie est construite plus moi voilà
j'avais une vie tout à fait ordinaire et
dont j'étais pleinement satisfait donc
du coup ça ne construit pas sa vie en
fonction du roman fait rire c'est une
espèce de bonus extraordinaire est ce
que vous êtes sur la ligne de celui qui
anime l'atelier d'écriture d'un slogan
il n'y a pas de talent c'est le travail
moi je m'en doute un peu delà de la
chose ce que vous vous êtes sur cette
ligne il faut être laborieux ya pas de
génie non je pense qu'il ya vraiment les
2000 ya trois choses il ya effectivement
forcément une part de talent il ya une
part de travail
je pense qu'une part de persévérance moi
j'aurais pu ne jamais être écrivain si
comme mon premier manuscrit était
requise et s'était dit tant pis voilà je
suis ni prof de fac et c'est pas grave
et effectivement il ya cette
persévérance qui fait qu'à un moment
donné il y avait cette très belle phrase
reste en écrivant qu'on devient écrivain
roues oui oui c'est ça c'est exactement
ça et je suis persuadé qu'à l'état de
manuscrits géniaux qui dorment dans des
tiroirs parce que les gens ont vu le
talent et le travail mais simplement pas
la persévérance de se dire j'ai été
refusé une fois je vais recommencer et
c'est alors - michel du cij
mais smith parce que je suis arrivé
voilà vous m'avez capturer j'ai pas pu
m'arrêter avant la dernière page mais je
ne suis que le modeste animateurs de
cette émission mon avis conforme comme
c'est seulement les chroniqueurs qui
vont faire on allait faire votre livre
et ont commencé dans ce carrousel et
surtout que j'ai été aux marquises que
j'ai vu et ombres de brel et gauguin
j'ai vu les statuts marquisien des
fameux tea qui joue un rôle important
dans le lui joue un rôle important
qu'ils font un peu peur mais qui en fait
sont plutôt des esprits bénéfique
éloigne les esprits j'ai vu saab louis
blanc en général j'ai vu le sable noir
j'ai vu cette forêt tropicale dont vous
parlez qui d'ailleurs une des rares
forêts primaires de la surface de la
terre
et puis bien sûr c'est marquisien traite
rapide qui sont très gentils mais au
compte en les croisant la forêt avec
leur poésie à part vos vacances
quatrièmement aussi tats-unis parle d'un
avis sur le lit ce qui va appareiller
relations soyez patient je parle du
libre et donc tout ce décor tout cette
ambiance j'y arrive crée donc en effet
une ambiance assez étonnante assez
envoûtant un peu collante et vous en
rajoutez une autre dimension inquiétante
comment avez vous décidé à quel moment
vous visez de camper une intrigue dans
ce lieu qui s'y prête à merveille
il y avait les deux c'est à dire que
évidemment les marquises
on connaît quand même un fervent de
choses sur les marquises et quand j'ai
décidé de dire tire mon roman va se
passer en marquise et qui ai moi même
chalet aux marquises pour vérifier sur
place
évidemment j'avais déjà des petites
idées derrière la tête entre le tatouage
entre les tiki entre les pétroglyphes
qu'on retrouve entre eux le cannibalisme
avant tout c'est évidemment brel
d'ariary gauguin donc il ya quand même
beaucoup beaucoup d'éléments pour
trouver sur hiva oa ket cette île des
marquises et qu'on retrouve pas
forcément sur d'autres îles de polynésie
où effectivement qui sont magnifiques
mais où l'histoire est belle alors on
n'y a pas eu ma dalton ya pas l'aimer
sable blanc voilà donc ces décès brutal
sas et puis il ya cette culture c'est à
dire qu'on l'oubli parce qu'on est
français parfois même on s'émeut poste
les marques qui sont en france médias ya
un véritable est nocif c'est à dire que
les marquisiens étaient cent mille quand
les européens sont arrivés on me fera
peu près vers 1900 et ils étaient 2000
un siècle après donc c'est quand même
toute une culture très particulière qui
a quasiment été éradiquée qui renaît
aujourd'hui et donc il y avait aussi
dans ce roman
cette idée de se dire tiens c'était
intéressant de se pencher sur cette
culture marquisienne qui je suis sûr
va revenir au goût du jour rien que les
tatouages les daaf sont des éléments
extrêmement connue il ya trente ans on
parlait quasiment pas de tatouage
marquis dire sans rien
oui alors moi j'aimerais revenir un peu
sur les chiffres michel bussi vous êtes
le deuxième auteur le plus lu en france
encore l'année dernière guillaume musso
a sacré passé douze ans de plus je suis
le poulidor bon les gens aient préféré
poule 2 puisque vous n'en plus finir on
se connaît un petit peu on s'apprécie
beaucoup ça vous fait rire ccc
classement c'est non non c'est pas que
déjà il est très très loin de vous et
moi de f1 ont très très loin devant moi
donc quelque part il n'y a pas fait main
des solutions voilà voilà
non non mais ce que ce que j'aime bien
c'est bien une chose c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui est extrêmement discret
qui n'apparaît pas dans les médias qui
fait son livre est donc ya pas ce côté
pipolisation et donc je suis très
admirative de ça parce que en étant le
premier vendeur depuis dix ans il
pourrait très bien se dire voilà écrase
tout le monde est en fait pas du tout il
resterait discret là dessus et vous
pouvez nous apprécie beaucoup son nom je
pense que c'est le point commun qu'on a
on pouvait nous dire on est entre nous
c'est quoi la recette pour faire un
best-seller en trois points et quand ça
sera ça a l'air d'être une blague mais
comment on obtient à coup sûr un
vestiaire parce que là vous n'avez plus
de n'avait plus de zig zag à plus
d'échecs et puis un lit ce qui marche et
l'autre qui marche pas on dirait que
vous avez une recette un rythme nous la
recette ça peut être un mot négatif ou
positif parce qu'une recette
il n'y a pas de recette parce qu'en fait
il ya vraiment les deux cafés vous avez
des auteurs qui vendent beaucoup mais
qui font globalement plutôt toujours la
même chose avec des notamment des slick
récurrent des rôles récurrents et
globalement ils sont dans quelque chose
où le lecteur va retrouver la même chose
et puis il ya des auteurs un peu comme
moi ou mais comme aime à les mid game
show qui font plutôt des one shot c'est
à dire des romans généralement assez
différent avec des héros qui meurt à la
fin et on s'arrête là et ça marche quand
même roman après roman dont il n'y a pas
de recette longtemps vides et il faut
faire du récurrent maintenance et pas si
évidemment chemin tenter enfin mais même
ça c'est fou comment vous faites pour
sortir un roman par an
enfin le rythme
bah on a on a un goncourt qui écrit un
roman en 28 jours donc
donc là ça fait face il ya pas de règles
moi j'étais enfin mehdi premier roman
pratiquement fait écrit en étant prof à
l'université donc j'écrivais le week-end
j'écrivais l'été j'écrivais et
maintenant que je fais plus que ça j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un temps infini
la crise c'est que vous êtes en train de
oui-oui pied d'urgence et dire qu'on
écrit depuis toujours et très jeune on
écrit dans l'urgence moi je ne sais
écrire que dans l'urgence je sais écrire
que si j'ai une demi-heure et v ne doit
pas perdre une minute quoi et du coup ça
permet de gagner du temps sièges avaient
peur de l'échec
je me suis que quand même avec tous les
chiffres qu'on peut citer sans
traduction tradition en 35 langues un
million d'exemplaires
est-ce que vous avez quand même
l'angoissé de l'échec à chaque nouveau
lieu bah oui bien sûr surtout donc quand
on essaie d'être original parle de ce
roman le soleil redouté pendant au moins
aller neuf mois j'ai cru que ça
marcherait pas d'ailleurs pour cela il
ya eu une manipulation et quand je le
faisais lire ça marche pas c'est à dire
que les gens ne tombait pas dedans on va
comprenez vous comprenez rien enfin ça
marchait pas donc il a fallu vraiment
des couches d'écriture successives pour
qu'à un moment donné le petit miracle se
produise et que les planètes s'alignent
et entre guillemets là on touche plus à
rien parce que voilà on va dire neuf
lecteurs sur 10 vous concerne le jeu
marche il là où exactement
reynaldo lecteurs à qui vous faites lire
avant de copains il comprend - intrigue
ou pas oui sur ce roman c'était encore
plus important est ce qui était terrifié
des cons bouger quelque chose il fallait
qu'il électeurs derrière donc avec mon
éditeur on avait prévu comme ça des
strates de lecteurs et parce que si on
bouge et on corrige et donc on faisait
des choses arrivent mais peut-être que
la fava me disais que mon aîné en fait
ça on fait des numéros zéro vous faites
des livres 0 écran qu'il est bon sens et
d'engrenages genre mais pas au hasard
yann leur buteur keaton cssa pour tester
ses comédies moi je pense que le on dit
toujours que deux formes de littérature
mais c'est pas tout à fait vrai il ya
certains livres pour lesquels les
personnages sont plus importants que
l'action d'autres pour lesquels l'action
est plus importante que les personnages
et il y à un livre que j'adore qu'est le
vicomte de bragelonne de dumas qui où
l'action et les personnages sont à
équidistance et je pense que vous êtes
pile dans cette lignée là et aussi je
dirais dans l'allier de pierre benoit
c'est à dire que moi je n'exclus pas que
dans 50 dans 100 ans vous soyez parmi
ceux qui vont véritablement rester comme
aujourd'hui pierre benoit est devenu une
idole des gens hyper les traits
alors qu'on se moquait de lui lorsqu'il
a sorti ses premiers livres et je crois
que avec une grande humilité une grande
discrétion
vous faites les livres qui vous
ressemblent ou la psychologie des
personnages est aussi importante que
l'action et peu importe que vous ne vous
inscriviez pas dans la lignée de joyce
ou de sollers qui ont fait autant de
bien les littératures qu'ils ont fait de
mal d'ailleurs parce que la littérature
est devenu un laboratoire
d'expérimentation et s'il ya bien
quelque chose qui vieillit extrêmement
mal c'est la littérature expérimentale
donc il faut également beaucoup de
modestie quand on vous lit quand on vous
lit quand on veut juge parce que en
littérature par définition personne n'a
la science infuse
ce n'est pas une science pour faire
court moi je vous aime bien est ce que
vous pensez à la postérité quand même
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui vit
voilà qui entre en compte pour vous
dites qu est-ce qui va rester deux mois
dansante en août ou lundi alors s'il ya
bien un truc donc on peut pas calculer
c'est l'austérité on peut se dire
j'espère pris dans un corps dans deux
ans ça marche encore alors là la
postérité
non vraiment pas en plus c'est très
compliqué quand on écrit alors c'est pas
ces écrits du roman policier du suspense
mais il ya tout et son contraire
je vais commencer par maurice leblanc et
arsène lupin tout le monde était
persuadé que maurice leblanc
disparaîtrait trente ans après sa mort
enfin que c'était pour le coup de la
vraie littérature populaire est
aujourd'hui arsène lupin oui mais lui nu
dans les écoles etc ce qui est marrant
pour distinguer les de littérature c'est
que lui a disparu pas son héros alors
que le vrai malraux il n'a pas disparu
mais ces livres ont disparu donc dans ce
qu'on appelle la vraie littérature c'est
les noms qui reste est dans ce qu'on
appelle la moins bonne littérature sont
les livres qui reste donc peut-être que
le moins beau littérature officielle est
la vrai j'ai ce n'est pas moi c'est
damon intéresse beaucoup parce que je
suis toujours frappé la condescendance
et mépris extrême quant aux qu'il ya
dans les médias l égard des vendeurs de
best seller c'est à dire qu'on les
méprise un petit peu on les invite pas
parce que ici effectivement donc voilà
bravo d'avoir fait ce qu'on aime ou pas
vos livres il faut reconnaître que vous
savez raconter des histoires voilà ouais
merci germanopratin qui fait que bat
laon pour africa paraissait pas si enfin
enfin oui il ya une forme de
différenciation mais plus que le mépris
il ya une forme d'indifférence c'est à
dire que et ce qui est curieux c'est que
les lecteurs qu'on rencontre sur les
salons dans les librairies sérieuse
souvent effectivement sont souvent de
très grands lecteurs c'est à dire qu'ils
avalent meinau
mon de livres tous deux fait de
connaissances en petites briques qui va
effectivement des derniers romans primés
à germer cheyrou du polar et et c'est
assez extraordinaire qu'on ne retrouve
pas forcément ça dans les émissions
culturelles chelle rae cet éclectisme
les grands coupables sur les prix
littéraires temps que quelqu'un comme
vous n'aura pas le goncourt et le
renaudot ce clivage existera il faut
qu'un jour guillaume musso et et
vouziers le médicis où le renaudot le
concours et ce jour là il ya un de l'air
qui va se créer le même statut que les
comédies aux césars et césar le théâtre
privé théâtre public d'ailleurs aux
molières en objet de faire deux à la
théorie bah oui à nier c'est pas normal
avec une petite nuance énergie expiré de
ce délai de lui avec une petite nuance
c'est à dire que je suis pas sûr que je
mérite le goncourt le le prix médicis et
créera c'est pas le but je suis déjà
connus font déjà beaucoup de livres donc
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait mais que que
ces prix récompensent des nouveaux
auteurs des nouveaux talents savent fils
part persuadé que des auteurs qui
vendent beaucoup n'est pas les faveurs
des médias n'est pas de prix c'est pas
grave je veux dire aussi c'est grave
c'est à dire que le prisme est
simplement celui de l'an viii
éventuellement de la jalousie et non pas
de la qualité intrinsèque du livre oui
quelqu'un qui a du succès douteux
on voit très bien au cinéma tu le sais
souvent les auteurs de cinéma les plus
radicaux finissent toujours par avoir du
succès quand ils insistent dans leur art
sans faire de concessions je cherche
jeune rider espagnol par exemple il n'a
jamais craqué et à force publique qui a
fini lui par craquer alors si je reste
ternie par une dernière question qui
rejoint notre débat qui le prolonge
peut-être un mot sur la mort de mary
higgins clark alors elle était très
auteur très très populaire avait gagné
un surnom reine du suspense est ce que
vous vous avez des influences de ce
côté-là aussi du côté anglo saxons vous
êtes plutôt amateur de polars français
qu'est ce que lis un auteur de polars
comme vous ce qu'il lit mary higgins
clark alors sur méricaine café terry
faisais jamais lu je crois il ya 30 ans
et est donc tout le monde a pris en 10
ans mais qu'at il faut qu'il dise
quelque chose qu'il m'arrive une classe
n'est jamais vue traitée assez gênant
mais par contre c'est lui énormément
agatha christie alors voilà donc
qui pour moi a inventé beaucoup de
genres peut-être que agatha christie
avait ce côté ludique dernière qu'il y
avait vraiment une construction à cette
loi ce que j'aime souvent dans mes
romans qui peut être ma marque de
fabrique c'est le twist alors que mary
higgins clark n'est peut-être plus dans
l'ambiance tourisme des retournements
est l'heureux enfin une péripétie
totalement inattendue quand on est
quasiment dans l'exercice de style dans
un jeu de manipulation alors que mary
higgins clark fait plus dans l'ambiance
dans l'atmosphère donc on n'est plus aux
confins du thriller me semble-t-il que
vraiment de l'effet de surprise même si
celui-ci merci infiniment en avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
soleil redouté votre dernier roman est
paru aux presses de la cité on lui
souhaite le même succès que les
précédents remercie beaucoup michel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]